[Music]
[Music]
while Tom and I were hunting on the
denali highway with my brother my wife
Rebecca grabbed her son Nathan and a
GoPro and went to seward alaska to hike
exit glacier with my family and they had
a wonderful time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there you go okay good boy oh oh good
boy yeah who's a good boy I am home
I am showered I actually smell half
decent and I back with my lovely wife
and we're gonna go out and get some food
how's that sound babe and the boys are
with Grandma and Grandpa
okay we're here at the fire cap and this
place is known for their pretzels but
not only they have these awesome
homemade pretzels they have cuts and
sandwiches in turn we also got some good
pizzas as well you guys hungry
been a long day I'm tired are you
alrighty we got ourselves some prentace
check out these pretzels there's a big
fat pretzel sandwich there that's pink
yours
while every trip to Alaska involves
hunting and fishing and adventures the
real purpose of this vacation was to see
family my kids have about 20-something
cousins and most of them live in Alaska
and they adore being able to see and
play with their aunts and uncles and
cousins
[Applause]
one of the highlights of this trip was
being able to see my grandparents both
of them are in their 90's and they have
been living in Alaska since before it
was a state and they love to see our
kids and our kids love to see their
great grandma and grandpa oh yeah the
silvers alright let's go get you some
winter gear buddy
if you need serious cold weather bad
weather fishing gear big raise
Army Navy and Anchorage is a good place
to go so we're gonna get Nathan here
some decent cold-weather gear for this
winter looking good there buddy what
over here oh you're Nathan I love
Carhartt they make sizes for big men
this is a large I'm six foot five and
I'm wearing a large tall what I love
about this place they got cold-weather
gear and big boy sizes this is size 14
socks man you know how hard these are
defined and they got them on sale like a
bag of them for 13 bucks love this do
you want me to put the sticker on your
shirt okay oh you're so by love these
things but I have absolutely no use for
them in Virginia and it makes me a
little sad
got some nice nice that's a good fishing
rod good I like the color too oh look at
that yeah yeah we're gonna fishing for
halibut here Saturday all right well
we're heading up to Palmer we're gonna
go hit the Alaska State Fair we've got
Grandma and Grandpa
Tommy Nathan aunt Melanie mom and dad
it's gonna be a wild time they're gonna
bleed us for every dollar and cent we
have
[Music]
driving but not enough attention to your
texting helpfully over there he's
watching My Little Ponies many times so
he's pretty much an expert Tommy yeah
well hold on Tom you gotta listen
oh yeah he's got a cowboy hat doesn't he
are you excited to go ride the pony
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
you rode a horse
[Music]
Oh your dad
bring some guys now that's a snapping
turtle right there that's an entity's
vision that's an alligator snapping
turtle
that big pavilion we pass in the way it
actually has salt I love Alaska where
you can get a camo jacuzzi tub
alright it's time to play some serious
midway games let's do this a protective
gel
oh sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't worry Nathan I believe in you you
like the cotton candy
it's good huh
there you have it a good time okay
like this course that's beautiful
got to get my obligatory Alaska grown
t-shirt there you go big cow boo
all that don't chase a dog chasing
gentle gentle Nathan
[Music]
well we've been here for about five
hours and we've only seen about half the
things there are to see here this is a
big fair but we're tired and the kids
are melting down the sugar highs wearing
off so we're gonna call it a day but
it's been fun
well it's another beautiful day here in
Alaska and we're gonna go get some
donuts
are you guys ready to go get some donuts
yeah all right we're here at golden
donuts in Anchorage Alaska this place is
an establishment used to be an old bank
so we're going through the drive-thru
with them that's a good-looking batch of
donuts right there there's good stuff
boy mmm hey guys ready to go gold mining
yeah all right let's let's head out to
the car
well here we are it's a crow Creek mine
and we're gonna do a little gold mining
it's unfortunately a bit wet so we'll
see how long this lasts but we're gonna
go give it a go we got our rain gear
we're gonna we're gonna man up and get
our shell some gold
alright guys come on alright well I need
your help guys you guys gonna be gold
miners you need to hold on to your gold
pan
[Music]
all right guys you're ready to find some
gold oh we're gonna be miners okay I am
NOT an expert miner but gold is heavy
and you it settles down into cracks and
crevices in bedrock now right here
you've got this big sheer rock wall and
you can see all this sediment pushed up
against the rocks for when the creek
floods it washes crap up against here
and then it would settle down
so my theory is we get the loose rock up
against here and we check that that's
where I would go and then we got a
little bit of bent water here for our
sluice box
so let's tap the sluice box first
okay got a pretty good current going
through our sluice box let's go get some
pay dirt over here Nathan are you okay
yeah yeah
yeah
go down in there yes got a bucket of pay
dirt Paul
grab a handful of dirt and put it in the
front of the sluice box like this let's
see what dad's doing see take a handful
of dirt and sprinkle it like this right
here in the front okay yeah
go for it
if there's a peas aren't there
yeah it's cold you see that
there we go Alaskan gold
oh there's another piece well it's
pouring down rain and the boys have fell
in the water which is very cold and
they're done so about 45 minutes of gold
gold panning got a few flakes
mission accomplished yeah let's go get
lunch
a little wet out here a little
design your 600 is he gonna speak that
way
No
Diaby do you want to drink the water
from the pipe so after all that rain and
gold-mining we are excited for some food
so to the Moose is to with the local
restaurant here and we got an apricot
chicken pizza and macaroni cheese with
reindeer sausage pizza so yeah if you
like super funky gourmet pizzas
check out the Moose's - great place to
eat your neighbors Nathan are you
sitting in the bed our kids absolutely
adore their aunts and uncles and
grandparents and cousins which is
fabulous because that meant babysitting
on this trip Becca and I celebrated our
16th wedding anniversary so I did
something that I've wanted to do for a
very long time I took Becca up to the
seven glaciers restaurant on top of
Mount Alyeska
it was a wonderful way to celebrate what
has been the best adventure of my life
being married to Rebecca for 16 years
[Music]
good root beer this is a raw halibut
wrapped in king crab look at that that
is hot cha that salmon with the
okonomiyaki and a kimchi sauce not too
shabby
take care of this is good stuff right
there look at that looking good babe
look at your steak here I think I'm
ready to try a steak again after
previous incidences this week we got a
Baked Alaska because we're in Alaska
happy Anniversary baby
[Music]
thanks for watching and if you enjoyed
this video check out part 4 of our
Laskin adventure and if you haven't done
it already don't forget to check out
parts 1 & 2 as well we put out new
videos every week so don't forget to
click subscribe to the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and if you'd like to see
more fishing videos with tips tutorials
and cooking recipes check out the
catfish and carp youtube channel as well
thanks
[Music]